thank you so much for agreeing to sit
down I really appreciate it
I have a million things I want to get
through but I have to start with the
reason I get to talk to you which is
your new movie this is the kind of film
that is really hard to make nowadays
because it's not an event movie and I
would so talk a little bit about the
challenges of getting this thing off the
ground and what you wanted to why you
wanted to be a part of it
well I loved film this particular film
in its script state because it really
spoke to humanity and it spoke to people
who were put in a situation that they
couldn't escape didn't want to be there
and the title says it all stuck you're
stuck in the subway you are nervous you
don't know when you're getting off there
are other people on the subway who are
also passengers who are any of socratic
and you sort of have to deal with this
pressurized situation it's also a
situation where you don't know what's
going to happen and in our film it's a
musical so we have the ability to be
able to reflect our emotions through
private songs that we sing to ourself or
songs that that come out of that kind of
uneasy awkward feeling that we sing to
others so you don't get a chance to do
these kind of movies a lot I come from
the Broadway stage I was on stage at
seven years old singing and dancing and
so it hearkened back to a time for me
that was very very important and when
you have songs to express emotion it's
wonderful because it allows you a little
more breath than words do and it allows
you a little more emotion without being
over emotional and pushing the audience
away this is a beautiful movie it is all
about connection it's all about how we
sometimes feel insecure in situations
it's all about people connecting and
once they do that then they feel
comfortable enough to share a piece of
their life that may be disturbing them
today you asked me right away how are
you doing today today's a good day for
me welcome feeling good had a bunch of
appointments to do but realize that I
felt connected to Who I am in my being I
always have to be a character
in film television shows on stage if I
can first get comfortable with who I am
on this particular day then I feel like
everything else flows from me from an
organic and original loving space this
movie came to me I read it and I
realized very quickly that it's the kind
of movie that people need to see not a
big temple movie you mentioned that not
a film that that will be seen in a
thousand two thousand theaters but a
film that has the possibility to be a
sleeper because the message is very
simple it's pay attention connect spread
some love hold the door for somebody do
something that you don't feel
comfortable with doing console someone
when you see them struggling even if
they're a stranger in public what what
how have we lost the art of living how
has that been lost to us it's been lost
to us because we have decided that well
today it's going to be all about me and
easy for me to do and say and live
because of the life I live you know a
lot of times I'm in front of the camera
talking about me oh sure when do I ask
how you're doing how are you doing today
by the way I'm doing excellent it's a
beautiful thing to be asked that someone
really cares and that someone would take
the time to check in and that's what
life really is so this movie to me I
will go to the nth degree to have people
know about it hoping and praying that
it's a sleeper not that you can see me
singing and dancing with the way you've
never seen me doing singing dance before
see me be taken for a homeless person
I'm sort of the conductor of all that
happens on this train mysteriously you
don't know his position but everyone
sees me and you go to the other other
end of the subway car he's homeless he's
combing his hair you know in the window
he's brushing his teeth with a bottle of
water
oh god stay away from that guy he's a
threat but you can't always you know
read a book by its cover
turns out he is the magic that allows
people to share their story and
instructs them to do so and and out of
that they are then faced with some kind
of consolation that they can make it
through their day because if somebody's
going to start again
they're gonna get to where they're going
maybe not in the timing they wanted to
but maybe in the timing that the
universe proposed for them because once
they get there they have had gone
through something that has allowed them
to reconnect again with strangers people
they don't know who might be able to
share a kernel love with them lightness
a little joke a little music a little
song that takes them out of their
thought form of living in the past all
the time you know when you do something
all the time it's all this always the
same every single day right you probably
have questions for different people you
wake up do the same thing all time
you're really what are you doing are you
doing this day are you doing yesterday
yeah we have things in our life to
define what we do all the time but when
something happens it's unexpected
unknown then all of a sudden we're here
here again wait wait I did expect that
to happen I think if I come to ask me
that question
maybe I gotta get really present and
live right now and not living my future
over my past if I'm not mistaken I
believe it was your mother that was an
opera singer yes so how long is singing
a role like this and I'm perhaps I don't
maybe you've done a role like this
before and I'm just not familiar with it
but is this like a role you've been
looking for or talked a little about
your family history with music well my
mother was an opera singer who came out
of caramel house in Cleveland went to
International House of New York and
eventually went to Europe on the
European tour of Porgy and Bess and she
wound up doing that tour alternating
that role with leontyne price she was a
great singer so I grew up in a musical
family also in a family it spoke
one-on-one language which was really
wonderful my father was an opera freak
he's from Naples Italy and so we were in
a home where I was really inspired by
singing in languages that I didn't even
understand and feeling the touch of that
Baptist music and Mahalia Jackson that
my mother played every morning and
jumping from that two areas of Pagliacci
and great opera singers that my father
put on the dueling stereos in the home
was amazing but it gave me a sense of
what
rhythm really is our lives are musical
they can be when we honor the connection
between ourselves you know I'm seeing a
woman now not to get too personal
who everything she does is musical she
doesn't realize it doesn't know it but
the way she speaks the way she moves
it's all very connected to a musicality
that we as reflected in the seasons of
our lives and why do we have seasons to
observe nature we have that to be able
to reflect the change that happens the
temporary nature of what our life is
really about we think it's one thing but
it really is another thing so for me
music has always been a very valuable
factor not not and I'm not a guy who
walks around with headphones in I don't
believe in that but I'm talking about
inner music inner music of life and so
that really hit me when I read this
particular script and listen to the
writer all of the music is original
which is really really wonderful guy
named Tim young wrote the music and has
done an incredible job he's a young guy
he plays a role in the film that is
really terrific he plays wonderful piano
and approach the music from a character
standpoint not that we're gonna stop
everything and just sing a song but from
how you feel right now
what would be your song you know and
that is original that's moving to me so
I've done 13 Broadway musicals where I
had to perform and really sing and hit
it right the character I play Lloyd is
raw and I realized I don't have to do
anything but just sing from my heart I
don't have to make it pretty I'll have
to make it nice this guy's is just raw
he recites Shakespeare he's very very
bright and very intelligent which you
don't know at the beginning of the piece
and then he breaks it to the song and
everyone just stares it'll look
something like he's crazy you say it
like a bad word you know it's like yeah
this is getting to the meat of the
potatoes of what we really think about
each other right completely and are held
back afraid to say
you know and I realize I'm that guy you
know I think isn't it was above all that
guy we become that we've been directed
to it somehow through our own thoughts
and emotions through our observation of
other people's thoughts and emotions
without being really real I was with a
friend now the querque race is a I know
she got nice shoes those blocks again I
bought a pair of Hugo Boss shoes and you
know I warm once I'm never gonna wear
again do you want these Hugo Boss shoes
I said my eyes lit up
that sounds good I'm a shoe guy a hat
guy yeah sure he brings out the shoes
they're these boxy he said worm once
right then these BOTS see Hugo Boss
shoes you like them what are you
supposed to say yeah like oh wow I'll
take them he asked me do you like them I
said you want the truth he said yeah I
said I want to tell you the truth I hate
about a water so he started bust whoever
does that he busted out laughing sure I
said I'll take him I'm just gonna give
him to some hobo on the street or
somebody else it's not that and I he we
are afraid that we're gonna insult each
other someone offers you a gift are you
gonna tell the truth and just take it
shove it away in a drawer put it down
every time you look at those shoes
you're gonna be like oh man hurry mother
gave me those shoes I didn't want him
why did I say that well because you
weren't living in the truth right so I
missed the moment I would have missed
the moment with him to be able to go wow
he was like wow that's so cool box them
up I said no you keep them dude I want
those you know but this is how life
works right Lily I have to ask you you
mentioned Albuquerque what is it like
for you walking around Albuquerque have
you paid for a drink ten years haha very
rarely oh yes very rarely do I pay for a
drink or a meal I have to force people
because people want to give me things if
I'm in that head of that character that
I play that we shoot our show better
call Saul in Albuquerque New Mexico then
and if I'm thinking in that Gus head I'm
very serious and people catch that vibe
because I get stops so much all over the
world and people don't know I'm like
this right so if I give that look it's
like wherever you want to sit sir
yeah what would you like you know and
the lady over there wants to buy you a
drink at the bartender wants to buy you
a drink and oh by the way your meal is
on us you know kind of great but it also
inhibits me from being completely me cuz
if I'm really me I'm saying no no no I
exceed three people in hearing I've
Bradley give me the business you know
the meal is 50 bucks and whatever it is
I appreciate that you want to give me
that gift and if they insist I of course
I take it you know I'll take a selfie
with them or whatever but it might
inhibit me from being truly all of who I
really am and that's who I would like
you to know no completely um took me
back into the movie a movie like this is
being made on a budget so how is it when
you're making something like this on set
in terms of did you did you know we got
to get the see two takes we got to get
this in three takes max like what does
that energy like on set well you know we
were very lucky to be in a place where
we had everything at our fingertips we
were shooting at the Sugar Factory out
in Queens and a Michael our illustrious
director who is really quite wonderful
comes from a musical and theatre
background they built a subway car in
that particular set area on the fourth
floor of that building was a recording
studio so that we could actually be
shooting on a subway car would be pulled
one or two at a time to put out and
record our songs so it felt like we were
in a neighborhood all our own we were
able to be in the subway I don't know
how that really happened because it was
a hard deal to do for a film that had no
money we were in the subway for two days
which was great to be out in the actual
subway subway car matched the car that
we were shooting on set perfectly so the
feeling was really phenomenal yes there
was time constraint and other technical
things that we had to deal with because
on the subway car set we recorded in
another place they would bring a speaker
in and put the music track in so he had
some music to sing by and not dubbing
ourselves so we would do it take where
we just completely did the song right
there on the set we do another take
where we would actually lip sync it to
what we'd already recorded to cover us
and then we would do a third take where
we could just do whatever we wanted to
do and so we have a spawning spontaneous
feeling about what's going
the great thing about doing a film like
this in time and money constraints is
that you are less apt to study
everything so closely and things
resemble what might happen if they were
really real because you don't have time
to to go back over it a thousand
different ways and shoot the hell out of
it you can get what is really real and
really encouraging we also have a scene
where the lights go out of the subway so
everything's lit by our own flashlights
brilliant less lighting less time less
things to match and you could go all the
way through the tape so for me this was
an experience of creativity reminding me
very much of independent film of the
early 80s in New York where you just got
what you got
specifically looking for the gems and
angles that you need but allowing space
for the actor to have moments that are
truly real and truly unexpected so we
had very little time but we were more
prepared than normally you would be
being in a place where you go in at 7:00
in the morning you go do a music
rehearsal you come back you block the
scene you let them light you come back
shoot part of the scene you go back to
your next song every day was like this
and you're always thinking oh Friday I
got to do this song and I'm gonna hit
that note and how will I do that you
know work with Tim work with Tim very
very all put together by our wonderful
director who had a vision for this movie
this movie man you sit down you watch it
because it's such a simple story and
then you're you watch more and more and
you hear about you know Omar Chaparro
story trying to put his kid through
school and it has an idea that she can
be a dancer and find some shoes in a
garbage can and has someone sewed them
up his dream working three jobs you hear
his story and you feel oh I remember
when I was a struggling actor in New
York working as a dishwasher grabbing a
cab at night auditioning in the daytime
Wow
yeah desire what pushes you to that
desire to better yourself in this place
that we call America you have you know a
guy like Lloyd who ostensibly is
homeless but has such great wisdom more
wisdom that you'd hear from the priest
of church on Sunday because he's telling
life stories because he's interested
people because it shouldn't people
finding themselves even if they think
he's a bum it has no place
to go there's a gym that comes from him
there's you know amy madigan who's just
so wonderful in this movie dealing with
the pain of a lost son reading you know
a shanti wonderful singer in our film
reading her energy and knowing that the
woman sitting across from her is
pregnant when she doesn't even know well
she knows but doesn't want to admit it
she's hiding it you start to read body
language of human beings you start to
see what people need and people people
need and you start to be not so
resentful about giving up giving it up
hey I see you're a little something's
going on with you because I can see you
know yeah you're clean today you're good
you're gonna cook what I knew that
before I asked you cuz we read each
other some movies all about that man
don't forget about why we're really here
it's really about what we have to share
it's really about what we're willing to
share and if you don't share it today
you may have another opportunity
tomorrow yeah I have a book I mean I
completely agree and a lot of people get
lost in their head and it's important
from films and crap alright to remind us
that we're all connected I think the
opportunity for this film to remind us
the connection even if we don't like
each other you know I gotta say we have
a character in this film who is being
chased by a guy and he really feels like
he loves her he wants to paint her he
draws things he sings and she's
immediately freaked out because she
feels like she had an experience of her
life with where she was raped
up on her and watching her and taking
pictures without coming out and saying I
really look like you freaks her out so
it played into all of her demons but in
the end this person is sincere and we
feel and know that's Assyrian honesty
and people will see it in this movie
they'll see the sincere very simple
message about connection they'll see
about overcoming all over the demons
that we haven't seen you have inside
your so it doesn't happen overnight it
happens through experiences through
talking with people it happens when you
judge someone I know when I judge
someone I go oh I just did that I just
look at that person's whole body and
judge them up and down and I'm gonna go
about my day feeling good about that
because they're different in some way I
thought oh why don't you look at them
and say Oh what do they need you know
someone's striving to do better but we
backed ourselves in very interesting
ways and sometimes we protect ourselves
from having the experience that will
uplift us and I got to tell you this
movie was so much fun to do because it's
uplifting film that is Kara takes you on
a journey of character and allows you to
look at these characters in this movie
and go oh I was like that oh I'm like
that oh I'm like that Wow
I'm gonna get so [ __ ] up yeah